hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Seibert
and we're gonna watch a trailer today
for a little game very small game not
many people know about it yet called
doom for something Quaker nuts what a
corrupt no what was that about it it's
quite calm
what was that for it's quick con it's a
vision oh do you know quake the cereal
brat god damn it case you guys haven't
noticed Dan Z expert I [ __ ] love you
I you doesn't know dooms one of my
favorite games uh my dad had the first
episode knee-deep in hell doom one and
he let me watch him play and then my mom
came up and caught me watching him play
doom and said you are not allowed to
play that game ever again my dad had a
Doom 3 and he would play all the time on
the computer with the gun yeah with the
gun yeah that was so much fun
is that what Doom is for yeah all PC
yeah I thought someone that actually
this might be on console as well okay I
guess uh ya know I [ __ ] loved playing
doom 3 actually damn that was so long
ago June 3
that was four years two years ago last
doom
what Doom 3 really yeah I'm sweatin doom
- probably doomed - if it was that long
ago definitely yeah yeah about 24 years
ago
yeah alright let's watch this trailer
I'm really white Brady
18
a powerful technology with infinite
possibilities mm-hmm instead we let them
in oh she used an unholy union I was
like really it's alien yeah Oh
now this brave new has gone to hell yes
it done did Don Diddley down
please creamy out good
oh [ __ ]
excellent you don't play as that thing
though right no no that shock that
everybody you're fighting that thing
Yeah right no yeah that was not the
quick con trailer that was the e3
trailer so someone lied to us okay still
however looks awesome okay so you fight
Satan in this huh
Satan with a gun I mean that's doom doom
is about going to hell oh I thought it
was a space thing it was it starts in
space the original is you're a marine
who's like pushed on to Mars I think
okay because you [ __ ] up and as
punishment you went to Mars and while
you're at Mars [ __ ] starts happening oh
and a portal from to hell opens up and
then demons start coming out Wow yes Wow
yes because Doom is [ __ ] awesome
you know what I think really raised the
bar for Doom was the movie starring
Dwayne the rock Johnson don't I did this
joke that you're doing right now you
Dwayne Johnson's performance in that
Robert was was honestly Oh his game
changer Oh video game adaptations yeah I
think that part that people loved the
most was when it was in first person
sheer cuz no one felt like I should just
be home playing the game they were like
this is a good movie decision I should
do a review of him that would be
actually pretty [ __ ] I just remember
watching doom in the theaters and going
why is the rice such a bad actor in this
movie what the [ __ ] are you doing like
every time you yell do yo e sound like
you is faking it you know what they
should let me write a do movie they
should like damn write a doom movie
you're talking about I would totally
write an awesome doom movie dude yeah me
too
it would be a remake of the movie
alright guys well thanks for telling us
to check out that trailer you ordered us
and we obeyed if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe by clicking
the subscribe button at the top here mmm
and Dan has a subscribe button too for
his channel good called that cyber
channel now cuz a lot of you guys have
been asking what's it called and I
thought it says it right here maybe you
have a mobile
one or something but it's that Seibert
channel first thing out pops up when you
type in it on YouTube if you can spell
it right yeah Seibert cyb ERT with a
silent F at the beginning fiber fiber
it's a combination Seibert cybernetic
it's a facade Berg I'm gonna make a fake
channel called cyber channel and it's
just gonna be a giant facade Oh Dan took
it to a whole other level
guys guys guys it's time to do shoutouts
that's freaking bomb Batman is awesome
and so am I go uh he said keep up the
great [ __ ] work and can i have a
shout out yes man you can totally have a
show where are the drugs
yes but of course that's not stunted
instead of other way my father drink I'm
literally just enjoying this show this
is I'm doing a trailer of all three good
night sleep well Thank You Batman
it's awesome your father I can't do
Michael Caine that's half your ago yeah
I'm alright yo fault yo father anyway
that is awesome uh you have a good day
everything is awesome and you are do
epic things cool when you're part of a
team does the best song of the year I
don't think it's nominated John Doe he
wants a shout-out John Doe um I don't
know who you are really I honestly can't
figure you out
it's like is your name even really John
Doe who are you where you from what the
hell do you want
we can't help you unless you tell us who
you are why are you here why is your
hair pink why are your genitals shaved
and
hanging on the outside why do you have a
tattoo of Liza Minnelli is there bananas
sticking out of your [ __ ] this has
been really weird John Doe let us help
you
let's Johnny Ruiz hey names Johnny Lewis
Namah Italian Puerto Rican oh yeah
Shaddai
really digging your videos hope you're
getting at that Veronica chick dude I
bang her several times a day
don't let her deny that how about a
shout-out sure sure you can have a
shout-out
Johnny Johnny rule let's get from the
streets went to prison at 15 years old
man yeah for being an old-time gangsta
see ah bull a God rest his soul
God rest his soul I stabbed him six
times he sleeps with the fishes huh hey
have you seen Boardwalk Empire
not yet it's a pretty damn good show I
really won't see it there's a that one
of the main characters is young Al
Capone and that's really cool actually
young yeah Al Capone yeah like when he
before he became mob boss when he was
like yogurt yeah it was like the younger
version is like an origin story of Al
Capone that's not the main focus but
it's pretty cool it's there it's
wrinkled now think of a sewed what I'm
Star Wars yeah hey look at that again
again anyway Johnny uh forgot that you
were in the room oh hey you're still
here
yeah dude I thought you would have
turned off the laptop by now yeah or
your phone you well I guess I'm gonna
stick around guess we can hang out yeah
I got we get I got [ __ ] to do yeah
should we well to what hey awesome feed
stop by we're gonna look we'll leave the
camera on yeah and we're gonna go we're
gonna go we're gonna go okay oh that way
how did he follow us into your room huh
Johnny get the [ __ ] out he lured the
[ __ ] outta - Johnny Johnny Johnny no
Johnny honey honey turn no no Johnny
Johnny oh my god Johnny huh just killed
himself
Oh God
dude I'm sorry to tell you guys but
Johnny Ruiz has passed away
god rest his soul